estamos en el problema 27 y me dice cuál
es la ecuación que mejor representa a la
recta siguiente y bueno tenemos justo
esta recta aquí en esta gráfica y antes
de ver las respuestas quiero que
pensemos un poco en la gráfica que
tenemos representada justo aquí cuál es
nuestra intersección con el eje de la y
es bueno si esta recta tienen como
ecuación también es igual a mx más ven
donde recuerda que la m es la pendiente
y b es la intersección con el eje layers
bueno si te das cuenta aquí
interceptamos al eje de las 10 en el
valor de cero cuando x vale cero y vale
cero estamos justo en este punto de
equip interceptamos a legisla si es en
el origen y por lo tanto puedo decir que
vale cero cuando x vale 0 10 vale 0 y
entonces esta ecuación se va a
simplificar de la siguiente manera bien
es igual a m por x porque la
intersección con el eje leyes
ahora para sacar la pendiente recuerda
que la podemos obtener pensando en el
cambio en james con respecto al cambio
en x así que vamos a fijarnos cómo
cambia esta recta si nosotros nos
movemos una en dirección en x cuanto
vamos a cambiar en 10 bueno podemos
crecer o decrecer sin embargo esta recta
crece y crece si te das cuenta hasta acá
hasta el valor de 2 por lo tanto cuando
cambiamos en yemen
esto lo puedo poner así cuando tenemos
un cambio en jeff de dos unidades
entonces cambiamos en x una unidad
cambiamos en x una unidad por lo tanto
la pendiente es 2 sobre 1 lo cual es 2 y
ahora si puedo decir que esta recta
tiene como ecuación ye es igual a 2 x 2
x porque estoy sustituyendo a la
pendiente y si te das cuenta es justo en
mi inciso b mi inciso b me dice que el
tiempo es igualdad 2x por lo tanto y
hasta la respuesta de este problema el
problema
27 y lo voy a quitar justo de aquí para
poner el siguiente problema voy a poner
ahora el problema número 28 y el
problema número 28 lo tengo justo aquí
cuál de los siguientes puntos se
encuentra en la recta definida por la
ecuación 3x + 6 james esto es igual a 2
y bueno si te das cuenta que tengo 4
puntos y creo que la forma más fácil que
se me ocurre de resolver este problema
es sustituir cada uno de los puntos para
ver cuál cumple esta ecuación que tengo
aquí por ejemplo tengo el punto aunque
dice que cuando x valdés 0 y vale 2 y si
lo sustituyó en esta ecuación de arriba
me va a quedar lo siguiente 3 que
multiplica a 0 + 6 que multiplica a 2 y
bueno esto es lo mismo que 3 x 0 0 + 12
bueno esto es 12 lo cual en definitiva
no es 2 por lo tanto el cisma ya puedo
decir que no es mi solución vamos a
intentar hacer lo mismo con el inciso b
cuando x vale 0 ya vale 6 y x
voy a sustituir en esta recta que tengo
aquí arriba 3 por 0 ok ya esto le vamos
a sumar 6 veces el valor de iu pero el
valor de ie6 entonces 6 por 6 y bueno
esto es lo mismo que 3 por 0 0 más 6 por
6 36 36 lo cual no es 2 por lo tanto
tampoco es el inciso b vamos a probar
con el inciso c
me quedaría 3 por 1 que es el valor de x
+ 6 que multiplica al valor de ye que en
este caso es menos un sexto menos un
sexto y bueno esto cuánto es igual es lo
mismo que 33 más
6 x menos un sexto más x menos es menos
por lo tanto aquí me quedaría menos y
seis por un sexto es lo mismo que uno
por lo tanto me queda 3 - 1 lo cual de
lujo si es 2 y ya tenemos la respuesta
la respuesta es el inciso c el inciso c
que es el punto 1 coma menos un sexto y
este punto se encuentra justo
esta recta muy bien voy a quitar este
problema y ahora vamos a resolver el
siguiente problema el problema 29-29
cuadra es la ecuación de la recta que
tiene una pendiente de 4 y pasa por el
punto 3 menos 10 y bueno lo que sabemos
que tiene una pendiente de 4 así que
vamos a utilizar eso si la recta esta
recta tiene como ecuación jeff es igual
a mx más b lo que ya sabemos es cuánto
vale la pendiente la pendiente vale 4
que es justo lo que nos dicen por lo
tanto esto nos quedaría bien es igual a
4 que multiplica a x + b y lo que
necesitamos saber es el valor de bp de
la intersección con el eje de la jez y
bueno para eso voy a utilizar este punto
que tengo aquí el cual nos da la
siguiente información cuando x vale 3
lleva l menos 10 y es un punto que pasa
por esta recta por lo tanto qué te
parece si sustituimos cuando vale menos
10 ok entonces tomamos el valor de 3 en
x
por tres ok más ven ok pero 4 por 3 2
entonces me quedaría menos 10 es igual a
12 ok
más ven y ahora si queremos despejar a
ver lo que tenemos que hacer es restar
12 de ambos lados y nos va a quedar que
ven es igual a menos 10 menos 12 de los
cuales menos 22 pase este 12 del otro
lado restando o reste 12 de ambos lados
ya tengo el valor de b&b vale menos 22
por lo tanto esta recta se ve de la
forma bien es igual a 4x más ver pero me
vale menos 22 menos 22 del lujo y si te
das cuenta es justo el inciso
por lo tanto la respuesta de este
problema es el inciso a vamos a resolver
el problema número 30 ya está por aquí
el problema número 30 que es este los
datos de la tabla siguiente muestran el
costo
de rentar una bicicleta por ahora
incluyendo el depósito rentar una
bicicleta y aquí tengo una tabla cuando
reventó la bicicleta dos horas el costo
en pesos es de 15 pesos cuando lo alentó
5 horas es de 30 pesos 8 horas es de 45
pesos si las horas h estuvieran
graficadas en el eje horizontal ok eso
es importante y el costo se estuviera
graficado en el eje vertical ok
cuál sería la ecuación de la recta que
se ajuste a los datos y bueno lo primero
que se me ocurre es utilizar esta
información h está en el eje horizontal
y se está en el eje vertical déjame a
ver si lo puedo representar más o menos
así por aquí tengo al eje horizontal y
este eje horizontal está representado
por h ok mientras que por aquí tengo a
mi eje vertical
ok más o menos se ve algo así y está
representado por c éste está
representado por ser por lo tanto h
ocupa en lugar de x y se ocupa en lugar
de y por lo tanto podríamos decir
la función del costo va a depender de h
dice va a haber más o menos así si es
igual a m por h más ven porque recuerda
que es una función lineal y además nos
están diciendo que h representa a las x
en esta oración que tengo aquí y se
representa a las 10 en esta oración que
tengo justo aquí y bueno si nosotros
queremos calcular la pendiente recuerda
que la pendiente va a ser igual al
cambio en este caso al cambio en la
variable c al cambio en la variable c
con respecto al cambio en la variable h
es decir cuando cambiamos de aquí para
acá la comparación de cuánto cambiamos
aquí para acá y bueno si sustituimos
esto me quedaría am si nos fijamos
primero en cuanto cambiamos en las horas
pasamos de 2 a 5 lo podemos escribir así
cinco menos dos ok y ahora si nos
fijamos cuánto cambiamos en el costo
bueno pasamos de 15 a 30 lo podemos
escribir como 30 menos 15
y esto es lo mismo que 30 menos 15 lo
cual es 15 ok y 5 menos otros lo cuales
3 por lo tanto la pendiente es 5 de lujo
ya tenemos la pendiente y la voy a
ocupar justo aquí en lugar de poner m
voy a poner que hacer es igual a m h es
decir 5 por h porque yo tuve la
pendiente más b y ahora para obtener a
ver podemos utilizar cualquiera de estos
puntos como le dice en el ejercicio
pasado de hecho se me ocurre utilizar
mejor este primer punto el cual me dice
que cuando h vale 2 c vale 15 cuando se
vale 15 am h vale 25 por 2 más ven ok
déjenme bajar un poco la pantalla para
obtener un poco más de espacio déjame
bajar un poco la pantalla déjame bajarle
un poco más yo que aquí voy a obtener el
valor del en para obtener el valor de b
vamos a multiplicar 5 por 2 y voy a
decir que 15 es igual
es más bien y ahora sí resto 10 de ambos
lados voy a obtener que es igual a 15
días lo cual es 5 de lujo ya tengo ven
ya tengo la pendiente ver si puedo decir
que la función del costo la función del
costo que depende de h es lo mismo que
cinco veces h la pendiente por h más bet
pero vale también 5 y si nos damos
cuenta
es justo esta que tenemos aquí es el
inciso sé si es igual a 5 h 5 y esa es
nuestra respuesta ahora tú podrás
verificar utilizando los otros puntos
para ver que en efecto es justo está la
ecuación que estábamos buscando pero
bueno es hora de quitar este problema y
voy a trabajar con el siguiente problema
con el problema número 31 el problema
número 31 y yo tengo justo por acá dice
algunos pares ordenados de la función
lineal x se muestran a continuación y si
te das cuenta nos dan una tabla cuál de
las siguientes ecuaciones se usó para
generar la tabla anterior
es justo igual al problema anterior es
muy parecido lo que tenemos que hacer es
tomarnos una función james que es igual
a mx + ven que genere esta tabla pero si
te das cuenta nos dicen que es una
función lineal y por lo tanto la podemos
representar con esta expresión de aquí
no tenemos nada raro como una equis
cuadrada o lo que sea y ahora lo que
necesitamos sacar en primer lugar es la
pendiente pero recuerda que la pendiente
es lo mismo que el cambio en james con
respecto al cambio en x así que vamos a
fijarnos cuánto cambiamos en este caso
vamos a cambiar de 1 a 3 ok entonces el
cambio en x me quedaría abajo 3 - 1 ok
mientras que el cambio y lleva de 1 a 7
me quedaría arriba 7 menos uno y esto
aunque es lo mismo que 6 entre 2 ok si
te das cuenta de aquí para camps
cambiamos dos unidades y de aquí para
cada cambiamos seis unidades y bueno
esto quiere decir que la pendiente vale
3 perfecto ya tenemos que la pendiente
vale 3 y entonces tengo la ecuación y es
igual a 3 por x + b y de igual manera
como en el ejercicio pasado vamos a
sustituir algunos de estos valores que
me dan y de hecho creo que este es el
más fácil cuando x vale 1 vale 1 así que
lo voy a utilizar justo aquí cuando
lleva la 1am x vale 13 x 1 ok más ven y
entonces de aquí voy a obtener que uno
es igual a tres más ven ok y si de aquí
restó tres de ambos lados voy a obtener
que ven es igual a uno menos tres lo
cual es menos 2 ok vamos a utilizar toda
esta información para encontrar la
ecuación que yo estoy buscando james es
igual a la pendiente pero en pendiente
vall de 33 x x ya esto hay que sumarle b
pero me vale menos 2 ok y si te das
cuenta es justo el inciso c en el inciso
se me dice que es igual a 3 x menos
y ya está mi siguiente respuesta ya
tengo la respuesta de este problema
número 31 y bueno creo que tengo tiempo
todavía de resolver un problema más por
lo tanto déjame quitar este problema de
aquí y vamos a resolver el último
problema problema número 32 lo tengo
justo por acá la ecuación de la recta l
es 6 x + 5 y la 3 y la ecuación de la
recta q es igual a 5 x 6 es igual a 0
cuál de las siguientes afirmaciones
sobre estas dos rectas es verdadera
inciso a la recta l y la recta q tienen
la misma intersección con el eje y m
inciso b las rectas el curso son
paralelas
enciso se en la recta l y la recta q
tiene la misma intersección con el eje x
y bueno aquí tengo un inciso de que dice
las rectas el curso son perpendiculares
recuerda dos rectas son perpendiculares
si la pendiente de una es el inverso
multiplicativo negativo de la pendiente
de la otra pero bueno como no sé cuáles
de estos incisos mi respuesta correcta
vamos trabajar con estas dos ecuaciones
que tengo aquí yo prefiero verlas en la
forma pendiente ordenada al origen
porque así es mucho más fácil visualizar
las y trabajar con ellas así que
trabajemos primero con la recta l y
vamos a pasarla a la forma pendiente
ordenada de origen la recta l tiene como
ecuación 6 x + 5 veces
james esto es igual a 3 ok y bueno si de
que quiero despejar ayer para obtener la
forma pendiente orden al origen voy a
restar 6x de ambos lados y voy a obtener
que cinco veces james es lo mismo que me
6 veces x ok ya esto le sumó 3 de lujo y
ahora voy a dividir todo entre 5 y
entonces me va a quedar que james es
igual y voy a obtener menos 6 entre 5 ok
todo lo estoy dividiendo entre 5 que
multiplica x +
3 entre 53 entre 5 ok ya tengo a la
recta de la pista en forma pendiente
ordenada al origen y que te parece si
hacemos lo mismo con la recta q la recta
q tiene como ecuación 5 veces x menos
seis veces y esto es igual a cero ok y 7
ciclo de despejar allí voy a restar 5x
de ambos lados y voy a obtener menos 6
veces
james ok esto es igual a menos 5 veces x
estoy pasando este del otro lado con
signo contrario y ahora voy a dividir
todo entre menos 6 y voy a obtener que
quien es lo mismo que y aquí hay que
tener cuidado
5 / menos 6 es lo mismo que 5 sextos
positivo porque menos / menos me da más
5 sextos x ok y si ahora visualizo estas
dos rectas estas dos ecuaciones en su
forma pendiente ordenada al origen
detenidamente a wow ya te diste cuenta
es justo de lo que hablábamos hace rato
si te das cuenta la pendiente de esta es
el inverso multiplicativo de la
pendiente de esta pero con signo
contrario y recuerdan que dos rectas
perpendiculares cumplen esa
particularidad que si nos tomamos la
pendiente de una ok en este caso es 5
sextos ya está pendiente le buscamos su
inverso multiplicativo que en este caso
sería 6 quintos y le cambiamos de signo
es decir menos 6 quintos
entonces obtenemos la pendiente de la
otra recta que es perpendicular y eso es
justo lo que habíamos probado en los
vídeos anteriores así que bueno ya puedo
concluir que estas dos rectas la recta l
y la recta q son rectas perpendiculares
y es justo la solución
este último problema el problema número
32 tiene como respuesta el inciso d así
que ya hemos acabado y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo